[Aplausos]
[Música]
sinónimo del desierto arena y calor el
sáhara es uno de los lugares más
inhóspitos del planeta
[Música]
un medio situado en el norte de áfrica
un medio árido hostil infértil tal vez
irrelevante que ni siquiera tiene un
valor estratégico en la geopolítica
internacional a primera vista de sahara
es poco más que un desierto el desierto
más extenso del planeta
[Música]
pero por supuesto esto es visual
política aquí la cosa no va de desierto
en este vídeo vamos a echar un vistazo a
uno de los conflictos más olvidados de
la política internacional habéis
escuchado hablar del sáhara occidental'
vale los que nos estáis viendo desde
españa seguro que sí pero para los que
nos estáis viendo desde otros lugares
del mundo tal vez no sepáis de qué
demonios os estamos hablando queridos
amigos el sáhara occidental es el más
grande de los 17 territorios no
autónomos reconocidos actualmente por el
comité especial para la descolonización
de las naciones unidas
[Música]
el sáhara occidental' está situado justo
al sur de marruecos hablamos de un
territorio que con aproximadamente la
superficie del reino unido- unos 260 mil
kilómetros cuadrados cuenta con poco más
de medio millón de habitantes 550 mil
personas de las que más o menos la mitad
conforman el conocido como pueblo
saharaui un pueblo históricamente nómada
al que la dureza del entorno les obliga
a moverse constantemente de un lugar a
otro
para muchos se trata de uno de los
últimos grandes pueblos sin estado que
existen en el mundo
ahora bien muchos os preguntaréis por
qué resulta importante un lugar
aparentemente tan insignificante como
este porque se habla del pueblo saharaui
y porque solo se identifica como tal a
la mitad de la población y la pregunta
más importante de todas por qué diantres
hablamos en visual polític de un rincón
tan inhóspito del mundo pues amigos
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poquito de historia
[Música]
un lugar de paso
durante siglos lo que hoy conocemos como
el sáhara occidental' fue un territorio
de paso entre marruecos y malí por el
que circulaban las caravanas de comercio
era el camino más fácil para evitar la
gran cordillera del atlas
de hecho esta característica de ser poco
más que un territorio de paso junto a
sus escasos habitantes y la práctica
inexistencia de asentamientos fijos hizo
que este lugar durante más de 500 años
estuviera sometido totalmente al control
de sus vecinos
el imperio de malí y el reino de
marruecos
[Música]
sin embargo cuando estos imperios
entraron en crisis y con ellos el
comercio entre ambos el sáhara comenzó a
no ser de nadie si me explico la escasa
población su carácter nómada y las duras
condiciones del entorno hacían que
establecer un gobierno funcional fuera
una misión casi imposible además de ser
un enorme derroche de recursos
[Música]
precisamente por ese motivo el sáhara se
convirtió en un territorio prácticamente
abandonado y olvidado al menos hasta que
una de las viejas potencias europeas
puso su atención en él
[Música]
a principios del siglo 18 españa empezó
a poner un especial interés en esta
región por dos motivos los caladeros de
pesca que potencialmente podrían
explotarse en su costa y la posibilidad
de establecer puertos atlánticos más
próximos al continente americano de esta
forma es como poco a poco comenzó a
crecer una relación entre españa y el
sáhara una relación basada en un interés
básicamente marítimo
[Música]
sin embargo amigos con la expansión de
los imperios europeos por toda áfrica
digamos que españa no quiso ser menos y
en el año 1884 reclamó como propio una
parte mayor del territorio
no sólo eso años más tarde acordó con
francia el reparto del sáhara y una
nueva extensión de su área de influencia
al menos sobre el mapa porque lo cierto
es que lo que se dice ocupación no llegó
hasta bien entrado en siglo veinte en la
década de los treinta
[Música]
y así así es amigos como se dio forma lo
que hoy conocemos como el sáhara
occidental la última colonia española y
lo fue de facto hasta el año 1975 cuando
de repente el panorama cambió por
completo atentos
[Música]
cuando las cosas se hacen mal sale mal
junto a link ecuatorial de sahara fue
durante toda la dictadura de francisco
franco o algo así como la última
reliquia del imperio español la última
prueba de un tiempo pasado que yacía
moribundo
[Música]
por supuesto la realidad será diferente
tan diferente como decepcionante más
decepcionante que recibir un juguete sin
pilas porque amigos esa supuesta
grandeza imperial no se veía por ninguna
parte excepto claro hasta en los
discursos nacionalistas del régimen
lo cierto es que en la década de los 70
el sáhara no era más que una especie de
piedra en el zapato un territorio
difícil de mantener del que no se
obtenía prácticamente nada eso sí
durante toda la dictadura el régimen
albergó una esperanza estaban
convencidos de que antes o después
aparecerían enormes riquezas ocultas
de hecho tras el descubrimiento de
algunos yacimientos de petróleo y
fosfatos a finales de los años 40 el
gobierno español colaboró con empresas
extranjeras para llevar a cabo
prospecciones a lo largo y ancho de todo
el sáhara para que os hagáis una idea
tan sólo entre los años 1960 en 1961 se
invirtieron más de 3 mil millones de
pesetas el equivalente hoy a 700
millones de euros
pero ahora bien la pregunta es hacer
toda españa' con esa estrategia pues sí
y no
veréis la buena noticia es que se
descubrieron al menos 27 potenciales
yacimientos de crudo la mala es que al
mismo tiempo se descubrió petróleo en
libia y en el mar del norte petróleo más
fácil y mucho más barato de extraer así
que por supuesto ninguna empresa se
lanzó a por estos recursos el tesoro
existía pero era muy caro extraer
pero un momento amigos porque ahí no
termina la historia españa no se fue con
las manos vacías
digamos que encontró un activo
relativamente valioso descubrió un
enorme yacimiento de fosfatos de
altísima calidad y muy barato de operar
los fosfatos son una materia prima que
se utiliza intensivamente en la
agricultura
[Música]
por así decirlo de golpe y porrazo el
sáhara pasó de algo parecido a la
prehistoria a la época industrial entre
finales de la década de los 60 y
principios de los 70 españa puso en
marcha la mina de bucraa una de las
mayores minas de fosfatos del planeta
sin embargo del arranque de la
producción no fue precisamente coser y
cantar veréis en aquella época el frente
polisario luchaba por la independencia
saharaui contra españa así que lo que
hice este grupo fue atacar una y otra y
otra vez las instalaciones mineras y la
cinta de 100 kilómetros que permitirá
conectar la mina con el puerto desde el
que luego se exportaban los fosfatos y
así claro pues no se puede de esta forma
la mina tuvo una producción irregular
hasta 1973 y no se esperaba que diera
beneficios hasta por lo menos el año 78
claro que para ese momento la presencia
de españa en sáhara ya era historia
[Música]
en noviembre de 1975 un convoy civil
marroquí conocido como la marcha verde y
formado por 350.000 personas avanzó y
ocupó el sahara occidental el gobierno
de marruecos aprovechó al momento
[Música]
francos estaba moribundo y el gobierno
español estaba pensando más en la
transición que en los constantes
quebraderos de cabeza del sáhara esta
forma españa abandonó literalmente a
toda velocidad sus posiciones en el
sáhara de repente este territorio tenía
un nuevo ocupante
[Música]
queridos amigos marruecos me dio bien
los tiempos y la jugada le salió a la
perfección no sólo ocupó prácticamente
de la noche a la mañana todo el sáhara
occidental sino que también se hizo con
el control de la mina de bucraa mina que
por cierto hoy sí operativa y que ojo
produce alrededor de 30 millones de
toneladas de fosfatos cada año
de hecho de esta forma es como marruecos
se ha convertido en uno de los mayores
exportadores mundiales de esta materia
prima cada año esta mina le genera
marruecos más de mil millones de dólares
[Música]
y dinero al que hay que sumar los
enormes caladeros de pesca de las aguas
saharauis y los potenciales yacimientos
de petróleo que con la tecnología actual
podrían comenzar a explotarse en otras
palabras marruecos antes se corta una
mano que dejar escapar el sáhara por eso
hoy la independencia este territorio
parece misión imposible
y ojo porque aquí comienza otra
rocambolesca historia veréis a efectos
legales ya ojo de naciones unidas- el
sáhara occidental no pertenece a
marruecos sino que sigue siendo un
territorio no des colonizado y por tanto
españa sigue siendo considerada como la
potencia administradora si lo habéis
escuchado bien atentos españa apoya los
esfuerzos de naciones unidas en favor de
una solución mutuamente aceptable que
prevea la libre determinación del pueblo
del sáhara occidental en el marco de
disposiciones compatibles de la carta de
naciones unidas- independencia ni está
ni se la espera el sáhara team status
llamémosle raro no es independiente pero
no es marroquí ni tampoco español al
menos no completamente por si fuera poco
además el territorio está dividido en
dos la parte oeste está controlada por
marruecos y una estrecha franja al este
que se extiende entre la frontera con
mauritania y argelia que es controlada
por el frente polisario
y es que veréis en 1976 el frente
polisario estableció en tindúf argelia
un gobierno en el exilio el gobierno de
la autoproclamada república árabe
saharaui democrática sí sí
así como suena el caso es que a día de
hoy son algo más de 50 países los que
reconocen a este gobierno que es miembro
de pleno derecho de la unión africana y
que tiene como objetivo lograr el
reconocimiento internacional de un
sahara plenamente independiente sin
embargo amigos hay un pequeñísimo
problema desde los años 80 poco a poco
más ronco se ha ido ampliando su control
sobre el territorio
[Música]
tal y como podéis ver a lo largo de los
años y a medida que ha ido extendiendo y
consolidando su dominio rabat ha
construido hasta seis muros divisorios
para impedir los avances del frente
polisario organización que ha terminado
limitando su control a la parte más
despoblada infértil y pobre en recursos
y es que marruecos también supo jugar
bien sus cartas en la escena
internacional
el frente polisario abrazaba el llamado
socialismo árabe así que al reino
alauita a marruecos no les resulta
complicado lograr durante la década de
los 80 en plena guerra fría el apoyo de
occidente para llevar a cabo sus planes
sin embargo a pesar de todo la onu sigue
considerando al sáhara occidental como
un territorio no autónomo pendiente de
descolonización y españa- como la
potencia administradora porque
pues veréis la raíz del problema viene
de los acuerdos de madrid que españa
firmó con marruecos y mauritania en 1935
justo después de la marcha verde
pues bien según estos acuerdos españa
transfería a la administración a
marruecos y mauritania aunque lo cierto
es que este último país se desentendió
apenas cuatro años más tarde bastantes
problemas tenían ya en casa
[Música]
la cuestión es que la onu no reconoce
como válidos estos acuerdos de madrid
porque no está permitido transferir de
una metrópoli a otra el control de un
territorio colonizado sin contar además
con la voz ni la opinión de su población
[Música]
precisamente por eso el comité de
descolonización de la onu sigue viendo a
españa como la potencia administradora
que tiene la responsabilidad de llevar a
cabo el proceso de descolonización
mediante un referéndum el problema es
que por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar a día de hoy el papel y la
influencia de española en sáhara es más
pequeña que la de marilyn manson en el
vaticano
marruecos es la potencia ocupante y
tiene todo el control y es aquí donde
nos surge una pregunta clave entonces
por qué demonios la comunidad
internacional simplemente no reconoce a
marruecos como potencia administradora y
dejar a españá a un lado pues amigos
básicamente porque eso sentaría un
precedente peligroso fijaos por un lado
reconocer a marruecos como potencia
administradora supondría de facto
legalizar la ocupación de territorios
por la fuerza y sin el consentimiento de
sus habitantes por otro marruecos no ha
mostrado la menor intención de llevar a
cabo ningún proceso de descolonización
su objetivo es la anexión plena del
territorio
y como lo cierto es que a nadie le
importa mucho el sáhara pues patada
hacia adelante la situación lleva
décadas empantanada no se reconoce la
legitimidad de marruecos para ocupar el
territorio pero tampoco se hace nada
para evitarlo así están las cosas pero
llegados a este punto hay una pregunta
que no podemos dejar de responder como
es la ocupación marroquí pues aquí aquí
amigos las cosas tampoco pintan nada
pero que nada bien para el pueblo
saharaui
veréis por un lado marruecos ha
propiciado la llegada de colonos
marroquíes que ya supone ni más ni menos
que la mitad de la población por otro
con total impunidad la monarquía
marroquí ha establecido un férreo
control y no dudó ni un segundo en
reprimir cualquier libertad política así
como atajar la más mínima libertad de
expresión
de hecho esto es lo que dice la mayoría
de las organizaciones de derechos
humanos internacionales por ejemplo
amistad internacional ha denunciado una
y otra vez la violación sistemática de
los derechos humanos de la población
saharaui y para colmo en todo este
asunto a españa' la potencia
administradora pues ni está ni se la
espera
amigos todo apunta a que marruecos ahora
con el sáhara lo que le venga en gana y
esto esto nos lleva a hacernos algunas
preguntas qué pensáis sobre este
conflicto veremos tal vez algún día un
sáhara independiente asumirá españa su
responsabilidad a la hora de promover
una transición democrática en este
inhóspito lugar del mundo aunque bueno
eso suponga dañar sus relaciones con
marruecos amigos déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios
y si este vídeo está resulta interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like como
siempre muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]